So, let's start with where we
were.
We were talking about
exponential growth in
populations.
And, we said we could describe
this as one over the dN/dt
equals some growth rate,
r.
And, in this case,
we're talking about,
let me ask that is a question.
As a model for population
growth, what's wrong with this?
What does this project?
This is N.
This is time.
There's no stopping it.
I mean, we'd be knee deep in
everything if populations grew
according to this model,
OK, because it just goes off
into infinity in terms of
density.
So, we know that this is
inadequate.
In fact, some people describe
the entire field of population
ecology as a field that tries to
determine why real populations
can't grow according to this
model.
In other words,
the whole field is trying to
understand what the mechanisms
are in populations that limit
their growth.
So, they don't grow
exponentially forever.
So, in this case,
this is really a maximum growth
rate.
We can call that r Max.
And in this case,
it's a constant.
So, when we're talking about
exponential growth,
the growth rate per unit time
is the maximum growth rate that
that population is capable of
under those conditions and it's
a constant.
So, if we want to plot it this
way, one over N,
dN/dt, as a function of N,
is constant.
It doesn't change as density
changes.
So, now we're going to take a
historical look at this.
Back in the 1920s,
two fellows named Pearl and
Reed wanted to model human
population growth.
And they looked at this
exponential growth equation,
and they said there's got to be
something wrong with that.
We can't just apply that to
humans, although if they plotted
as a function of time,
and this is humans in the US
from 1800 to 1900,
and this is the human
population size,
if they plotted this on this
curve, they got something that
looked like this.
So, it kind of looked like
exponential growth.
But, when they went in it
actually looked at one over ND,
dN/dt, which would be the slope
along here, they found that it
looks something like this.
In other words,
the actual growth rate of the
population was decreasing as the
number of humans increased.
And this is called a density
dependent response.
00:04:17<clear/>
OK, so if we look at this,
remember from last time that r
is equal to the birth rate minus
the death rate,
right?
So, we can look at,
this is just a simple cartoon
drawing of what's going on here.
Density dependent factors
regulate population size.
So, if we plot one over ND,
dN/dt as either a birth rate or
a death rate,
as a function of population
density, when you have density,
really the one that's the most
important here is looking at
this one, that death rate
increases as population
increases, and birth rate
decreases.
And you have an intersection
here where birth rate and death
rate are equal,
and your population's going to
stabilize there where there will
be no change in population
growth.
And these density dependent
birth rates and death rates
introduce a stabilizing factor.
As N increases,
r decreases in the population.
And that's what brings
population back into some sort
of equilibrium.
OK, so all right,
forget that.
So, let's go back over to Pearl
and Reed.
We're going to stay on the
board for awhile.
So the question is,
how do we modify that equation,
our simple exponential growth
equation, so that it more
realistically describes real
populations that can't grow
totally unconstrained?
So what Pearl and Reed did,
how do we modify the
exponential growth?
So, here's what we want the
characteristics to be of this
equation.
We want one over N,
dN/dt, to go to zero as N gets
large.
And we want it to go to our
max, the maximum growth rate,
when N approaches zero.
In other words,
at really, really low
population density is,
you can effectively have
exponential growth because
nothing's limiting you.
When the density gets very,
very large, you want this
growth rate to go to zero.
So, they came up,
so let's plot this N.
This is T, and here's our
exponential growth equation.
And they came up with a
function that looks like this.
So, this would be one over N,
and to describe this,
we have this equation.
And this is called the logistic
equation for reasons that are
historically obscure.
This is a French term that has
something to do with,
anybody know,
who speaks French?
It has to do with something
military.
Anyway, I've never been able to
figure out why they call this
the logistic equation.
But it doesn't matter what it's
called, this is what it is.
And K here is the carrying
capacity of the environment.
It's the maximum number of
organisms were the population
levels off, OK?
All right, so let's look at
this.
Let's replot this,
because it's easier to analyze
the features.
We're going to plot one over N,
dN/dt as a function of N.
If we want to rewrite the
equation, one over N,
dN/dt equals our max.
We're just rearranging that
equation to make it easier to
visualize.
OK?
So that we have a line that we
can put that on,
such that K is the X intercept,
and what's this?
Our max, exactly.
So, you can see these features
over here at this plot,
right?
So, as this goes to zero,
or as N is very large,
one over N, dN/dt goes to zero.
And, when N is very small,
one over N, dN/dt is near our
max.
You're basically growing.
You're over here where the
exponential growth curve and the
logistical curve are essentially
the same thing.
Yeah?
Do I have something wrong?
Oh, very good,
very good, very good.
Thank you.
Absolutely right.
OK, so the slope here is going
to be minus r max over K.
.
OK, so here we have a nice
density dependent response.
OK, let's analyze some more
features of this.
Just looking at the exponential
and the logistic,
just to summarize,
one over N, dN/dt as a function
of N, and if we just look at the
dN/dt as a function of N,
for exponential we already said
that this is a flat line,
right?
It's a constant,
but the actual change in
numbers as a function of time is
a straight line,
whereas for the logistic,
one over N, dN/dt as a function
of N, what does this look like?
We just did it,
so we are summarizing here.
But here's one that I want you
to think about.
What does the dN/dt look like
as a function of N if
something's growing according to
the logistic equation?
Like this?
Yes, there you go,
like that.
Right.
Because there is an inflection
point here, right?
So, this is what's sometimes
called the optimum yield,
and believe it or not,
this model is actually used in
fisheries conservation for
years.
Now we know that it's so much
more complicated than that that
you can't just set the model is.
But one could argue that if you
are managing a population that
you want to harvest,
that you try to keep them at
the density at which the dN/dt,
the production of organisms,
is maximal.
So, you try to maintain a
population there at that point.
One of the features of the
logistic equation is that it
assumes instantaneous feedback
of the density on growth rate.
In other words,
it says in a population of a
certain density,
the results in terms of
offspring will be instantaneous.
And we know that's not true.
So, this is an
oversimplification.
Even in the simplest organisms,
even microbes in a culture,
say you suddenly starve them up
some substrate that they're
using.
It takes a while for their
biochemistry to readjust before
that.
They might have one generation
that's still at the same growth
rate as it was before,
before the biochemistry
readjusts and says,
whoa, we can't keep going at
this rate.
Slow down.
And then for higher organisms,
you might have a whole
generation before that sets it
in.
Plants that make seeds,
etc.
So we know that there's a
problem here.
So, people have tried to
introduce time lags into the
equation, and we don't have
time.
I mean there's lots of really
neat things that you can do with
this.
If this was an advanced ecology
course, you'd be modeling it on
your computer,
and putting time lags in,
and see what happens and all
that kind of stuff.
So we don't have time to do any
of that.
I show you this more as a way,
I want you to learn how
population ethologists think,
not that this is actually the
most important model that ever
existed.
So how do we introduce time
lags into the logistic?
Well, the simplest way is to
introduce time.
So, we're going to say dNt/dt.
Let me just make sure that's
not ambiguous.
dNt/dT, is equal to r max times
N at that time t times K minus
Nt minus tao.
In other words,
the density at some time,
tao hours or days or whatever,
earlier than t,
divided by K.
So, what this says is that the
growth rate of the population is
a function of the density up a
little bit earlier,
or some amount earlier than the
time at which we're measuring
the growth rate.
So t or tao is the time lag
between sensing environments,
and change in growth rate.
So let's look at what that
means in terms of,
this brings us to another level
of complexity.
So let's look at the
possibilities here.
So, with no lag,
we have our logistic equation,
right?
The population just reaches the
carrying capacity and levels
off.
With a very short lag,
and of course you have to play
with this to understand what I
mean by short,
long, and medium because you
have to change all the different
parameters.
But if you have a short lag,
what you get is an actual
overshoot of the carrying
capacity in the near term
because the feedback hasn't
kicked in.
But then, it will come back and
it will level off at the
carrying capacity.
If you have a medium lag,
you will often see something
like this where you get a couple
of oscillations in here.
But it levels off at the same
carrying capacity.
And, a long lag,
you can end up with behavior
that ultimately ends up in the
population crashing.
And we don't have time to
analyze this,
but at the end of the lecture
I'm going to come back to why
this is so important in terms of
human population growth.
And for those of you who are
interested in complex systems
and chaos theory,
the logistic equation in its
discrete form actually will go
chaotic for certain parameter
values.
And for a long time,
for those of you who don't know
what I'm talking about,
just ignore me.
And for those who are
interested ought to spend a
minute on it.
For a long time,
this equation goes into a state
of sort of chaotic oscillations,
but that can be described
mathematically.
And for a long time,
ecologists kept looking at
populations trying to see
whether, indeed,
they were growing according to
this chaos theory and it hasn't
really developed to anything,
but it was interesting.
Chaos theory first started
coming to light;
the sea collision was one of
the first that people started
looking into,
coincidentally.
But just because an equation
has certain properties,
it doesn't mean that thing it's
trying to model has those
properties.
So that was a really
interesting development.
OK, so let's go back to Pearl
and Reed.
Where did they go?
Oh, they're up there.
OK, so this was all a
digression.
So Pearl and Reed were looking
at the human population data,
and trying to model it.
And they showed that they had
this density dependent response.
They developed this equation in
order to describe it.
And then, they looked at the
data again using this graphical
formulation.
So, let's look at that.
We're just going to use the
graphic method,
because it's easier to
illustrate.
And now, we're looking at the
human population in the US,
and this is one over N,
dN/dt, and this is N in
millions.
And so, they have some data
points that they put on here.
This is 1800 to 1810.
So, they have different data
points for different intervals,
and their last point here was
1900 to 1910,
an average of the population
size.
And so, they projected down
here there were 100 million
people then.
So, they said,
so they asked the question:
OK, we're modeling this
population, we're saying it
grows according to the logistic
equation, we can predict what
the carrying capacity in the
United States for humans by
simply doing a regression
through this,
and seeing where it intercepts.
So, that should be the carrying
capacity.
And they predicted that we'd
have 197 million when we reach
the carrying capacity.
And that was in the year 2030.
So that was a prediction of
their model back in the 1920s,
that the carrying capacity of
the US for humans was 197
million, and that that would be
reached in 2030.
Well, they missed it by a lot.
So, let's look at the data,
which is not surprising.
Here's 1965.
We reached 200 million way
before 2030.
1990, 250 million,
and actually today,
at 10:45 this morning,
because I looked it up on my
trusty population clock on the
Web,
we had 295,979,238 people.
This is also done by modeling,
we're not counting people one
at a time.
But this website is keeping
track based on various models.
And, based on the models that
we have today,
in 2030 we should have about
345 million.
But these models are based on
something entirely much more
complex now than the simple
logistic equation.
OK, so the contribution of
Pearl and Reed was to be yet to
get people to start thinking
about the feedback mechanisms,
how to model population growth,
and think about the feedback
mechanisms in that model.
You don't have that in your
handout, but it's not important.
It's not on the web,
but if you care about it,
there is the website that keeps
track of human population in the
US.
So, here's the total population
number that I got this morning
at 10:14 and 17 seconds off the
web.
And these are just some
interesting statistics for the
US, and I have them for the last
three years: one birth every
eight seconds,
one death every 13 seconds,
one migrant every 26 seconds,
and a net gain of one person
every 12 seconds.
So they're keeping close track
here.
OK, all right,
so now are going to move on to
global population growth,
humans on the earth,
the whole shoot and match.
And, there's this wonderful
book for anyone who's interested
by Joel Cohen,
called, How Many People Can the
Earth Support?
And, it's a great book for MIT
students because it's a
wonderfully nerdy account.
I'm a nerd, so I can say that.
I'm a total nerd.
But it's just a wonderful
account, analysis,
if you analyze human population
growth, and at the same time
looking at the phenomenon in a
totally objective way.
He's a theoretical ecologist.
So, this is in your textbook.
But, it's from this book.
And, it's from 10,000 B.C.
up to here we are today,
the population on Earth in
billions.
And, this is back in the hunter
gatherer era.
We had 4 million people.
And this was a small revolution
at the time, the introduction of
the agriculture and
domestication of animals allowed
for higher birth rates,
and so had a little blip,
went up to 7 million here.
And then for a long time,
there was just no change in
human population on Earth.
And so then,
here you start to get,
I'm not sure what started this
up rise.
Maybe when we see the next
slide we'll see.
No, I'm not sure what started
that.
We'll have to look into that.
Maybe just the accumulation of
people that you can't see on
this scale, here's the bubonic
plague, a decrease.
Here's the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution and the
introduction of modern medicine,
which greatly reduced
mortality.
So, you see this incredible,
and here's fossil fuel,
increase in the population of
humans on Earth.
So, if you look at this curve,
you think, oh my God,
we're in the middle of this
incredible exponential increase.
And, the reality is this
doesn't fit at all in an
exponential model at all.
I mean, if you tried to fit
that to our simple exponential,
it does not fit.
We are going to explain what's
happening here in a minute.
So here we are at 6 billion
people.
And we hit 6 billion in 1999.
And here we are with a steady
increase.
I've just got the last three
years.
This marks the lectures that
I've given in this class.
Every year I check in and see
where we are.
It's kind of a living document.
And, we're now projected to
reach 9 billion and level off.
When I first started teaching
about human population growth,
the projections were at 12
billion.
And I'm not that old.
This number keeps changing,
and luckily it's changing in
the right direction.
We keep predicting fewer and
fewer humans before it will
level off.
But it's still 3 billion more
humans than we have now,
and many people think now were
already beyond the carrying
capacity of the Earth.
So, I'm not saying not to
worry, I'm just saying that at
least it's going in the right
direction.
So, in Cohen's book,
he analyzes this,
sort of the history of humans
on Earth as having four major
evolutionary changes where you
have the dramatic change in
population growth.
You have local agriculture in
8000 B.C.
And, the doubling time of the
population before and after
those evolutions went from what
he estimates to be 40,000 to
300,000 years for a population
to double down to 1000 to 3000
years for the population to
double.
In other words,
this is an incredibly faster
growth rate, because this is
doubling times.
And then, with global
agriculture in the 1700s,
again you have a shortening of
the doubling time of the
population.
And then in the 50s with the
introduction of real public
health across the world,
another reduction,
and luckily in the 70s,
with the introduction of
fertility control,
at least in the developed
countries, is the first time you
actually see a shift.
We've gone from growing faster,
and faster, and faster to
actually growing more slowly.
The doubling time is extending.
So, the good news is we're not
in some kind of runaway
population growth that's going
to continue forever.
We've already peaked out as a
globe, and we are going to level
off in terms humans.
And the real big question is
when we level off,
will we be above the carrying
capacity of the Earth?
Have we overshot K?
And we don't know yet because
these feedback mechanisms
haven't come back.
So, let's now analyze this a
little bit more before we look
at it in that context,
because this is an important
thing.
First of all,
before we do that,
I want to remind you that all
of these lectures are tied
together because remember this
from lecture 20 when we were
talking about biogeochemical
cycles?
And, here's the same population
size and billions on Earth,
the brown curve.
It's smoothed over,
and these are the greenhouse
gases, concentration of
greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere.
This is the human footprint.
This is how we've changed the
metabolism of the Earth,
by this explosive growth of
humans.
And one more slide just showing
you that this is another way to
look at it, showing that the
growth of the global population
has peaked.
So, over here,
each of these is the population
in billions, and it basically
shows you the number of years
necessary to add a billion.
And you could see that it's
taking longer and longer to add
a billion.
You can see that there is an
inflection point here.
So, using the tools that we've
developed to analyze
populations, let's look at why
this growth is leveling off.
What caused the growth to begin
with, and why it's leveling off?
And the really important
feature here is what's called a
demographic transition.
This is what we are going
through on the Earth right now
in terms of human population
growth.
And, the way we look at this,
we are planning birth rates
here, which is the pink one,
and death rate here,
which is the green one.
And, when birth rates and death
rates are both uniformly high,
which is the way it was back in
the early days when we didn't
have fertility control,
and we didn't have modern
medicine.
So, you had a lot of babies and
a lot of people dying.
And growth rate,
and so this is the total
population.
So, you don't have much
population growth.
Then, what happens,
you get to a place where you
have a very high birth rate.
Birth rate continues to stay
high, but with the introduction
of public health,
and modern medicine,
we were able to keep people
alive a lot longer.
And, that came in advance of
fertility control.
So, what happens,
when these two curves deviate
from one another,
you have explosive growth,
and that's what this big
exponential shoot is.
But then, if you then reduce
the birth rates through
fertility control to match the
death rates, you then have low
birth rates and low death rates.
Then you have no population
growth, OK?
So, it's very simple and
intuitive when you understand
what's going on,
but I don't think that most
people really have come to the
point of thinking about it like
that.
And where we are on Earth today
is the developed countries have
gone through their demographic
transition.
And you have a sense of that
just from looking at family size
in these countries.
So, if we look at,
this is Sweden as an example of
a developed country.
And this was 1800.
And this is 2000.
You see something like this.
This is just an approximation.
This is the birth rate and this
is the death rate,
and the population growth rate
looks something like this.
The populations leveled off
whereas if you look at a country
like Egypt over the same time
frame, and you can get these
curves off the web easily,
it looks something like this.
You have a high birth rate.
And death rate has gone down,
but they're not matching each
other at all.
So, population look something
like this.
It hasn't even begun to level
off.
So the real trick is,
in terms of trying to level off
at someplace lower than 9
billion, is to get the
birthrates in the developing
countries to drop as fast as we
can.
And that will determine the
level at which humans will level
off on Earth.
So, let's just briefly,
let me go back over here,
and let's go back over this
carrying capacity.
And this is basically what Joel
Cohen's book is about,
where he says,
how many people can the Earth
support?
He's asking,
what's the carrying capacity of
the earth for humans?
And here are the possibilities.
And of course,
I'm simplifying the most
complex system that we know into
a simple two-dimensional graph,
but I think it's a good way to
think about it.
Here's the way we've been
living on Earth.
We have been growing like this.
Granted, we're starting to
level off, but we've been
growing like this.
And what we've been assuming,
is that the carrying capacity
will grow with us,
OK?
We can handle as many humans as
we want to put because we,
smart people,
with technology can increase
the carrying capacity.
If we don't have enough grain,
we'll genetically engineer to
make more grain.
We can fix it;
we can fix it,
so let's just go with the flow.
And indeed, technology has
greatly increased the carrying
capacity of the earth for
humans.
There's no doubt about it.
But there's got to be a limit.
So, is this the model that we
want to go by?
So, some people argue,
so, the climate,
we'll fix that with technology.
We can fix any of this with
technology, and if things get
really bad, we'll go to Mars;
we'll terraform Mars.
We'll colonize planets.
That's not that far-fetched,
so why should we worry about
all these humans on the Earth?
We'll just figure out,
we'll go out and find new
places.
So that's one model.
Another model is,
if we're going to do this,
here's what I call the
optimistic model.
Well, I guess this is the super
This one assumes that it'll do
something like this that we may
overshoot.
And then birth rates,
and if you want to you can
easily describe a scenario that
says that we have overshot,
that this whole environmental
movement, the measurement of
toxins in our environment,
the global change,
all of that is really
overshooting the carrying
capacity.
And we wouldn't be worrying
about things that we're worrying
about if we hadn't overshot it,
but that if we get our act
together,
we won't have eroded the
Earth's natural system so much
that we can come back to a
stable level.
And then, of course,
the pessimistic scenario is
that, indeed,
we've overshot,
and we've overshot so much that
we have eroded the carrying
capacity,
and that we will level off at
some level that the Earth will
no longer be able to support the
level of humans that it can even
support now, that we have lost
so much topsoil,
and modern agriculture won't be
able to overcome that,
that our water will be
polluted, that the climate will
change so dramatically,
the fisheries will be
eliminated, yada,
yada, yada.
I shouldn't say yada,
Those are catastrophic things.
Erase that from the tape!
Every once in a while,
I remember I'm being taped.
So, those are bad things,
not to be yada,
yada, yada'd.
So, anyway, this is what some
people are worried about,
that we are,
indeed right now,
in your lifetime and in fact
mostly in your lifetime,
you are inheriting this,
notice the time frames on this
graph.
I mean, this is just this
little snippet of time in the
history of life on Earth where
all these dramatic things are
happening.
And we just happen to be living
in it.
Just think if you're living
back here, and thousands and
thousands of years went by,
and nothing changed.
OK, so we don't have any
answers, but this is a way to
think about it,
and a lot of people are putting
a lot of energy into modeling
the systems, and try to figure
out where we are the scariest
trajectories.
So, the next two lectures
Professor Martin Polz,
who is a professor in civil and
environmental engineering,
and the microbiologist is going
to come in and talk to you
about, again,
its population economy.
He'll talk to you about
population genetics,
and some really exciting work
that's going on in the field now
using genomics to decipher
evolution and population
biology.
And then I'll be back with some
really neat DVD clips.
So, come back.